We've used the term social
contract several times already,
so let's take a
look at what did we
mean by this post-World
World War II social contract?
And why did it work
so well for so many?
If you were born
between 1946 and 1964,
you're a member of what we
call the Baby Boom generation.
And chances are you did
quite well, because you were
able to follow
your parents advice
of working hard,
staying in school,
and being able to improve on the
standard of living you achieve
for yourself and for
your family compared
to what your parents had.
So was this all just
a matter of luck?
Is there some iron law of
economics that achieved it?
Well, neither are true.
It took a lot of hard work
and a lot of invention
on the part of labor and
management leaders of the time.
America came out of World War
II with an enormous amount
of pent-up demand
for consumer goods,
because we were
focused on building
the economy for the war.
So we had to convert
from factories
that made tanks and
military airplanes
to factories that made cars
and other kinds of goods
and services that were in high
demand in the post-World War
II economy.
And that created what we call
the post-war social contract.
Now, you've seen
this diagram before.
It shows that over the
post-World War II time period,
wages and productivity
moved in tandem.
And so as the
economy got better,
so too did wages and
living conditions
for the vast majority of
families of that time.
So how did that work?
Well, as I said, we've had
an enormous amount of growth
in construction,
in heavy industry,
in rebuilding the economy
after World War II.
We had the rise of
mass production.
We had automobiles
coming out of our ears.
Here's a picture of
how Ford and General
Motors and other companies
were able to produce millions
of vehicles for the mass market,
largely similar kinds of goods
and services that
people were looking for.
So it was out of
this time period
that unions began to grow.
In the post-World World
War II time period,
unions grew to about 30% to 35%.
But union growth
didn't come easily.
It took a lot of battles
between labor and management
in the steel industry,
in the auto industry.
General Motors had to
experience a sit-down strike
in their plant in 1937
before unionization
was accepted by General Motors.
This is an example
of what's called
the Battle of the
Overpass, where
the auto workers' leaders--
led by Walter Reuther,
who we're going
to hear about a little bit
more specifically in a moment--
had to fight with paid security
guards hired by Ford Motor
to try to keep the union out.
So this was a
battle that went on
not only in autos but in steel
and in many other industries.
But once it was successful,
and once unions were organized,
you got something called
the postwar social contract.
This is an example of
Walter Reuther, here,
negotiating and signing an
agreement with General Motors
which was called the
Treaty of Detroit,
where the parties agreed that
they would increase wages
by the rate of growth
in the cost of living
and the overall average rate
of growth in productivity
in the economy.
And it was that agreement that
allowed wages then to grow,
and why we got this
tandem movement of wages
and productivity for so many
years in the postwar time
period.
But that was just
the auto industry.
How do we get this to
spread across the country?
Well, to understand
that, we have
to introduce another
term, something
that in labor
relations terminology
is called pattern bargaining.
What would happen is, you
negotiated a wage agreement
at, let's say, General
Motors; and then the union
would carry that same
agreement to Ford and say,
if you don't want
a strike, then you
should agree to the same wage.
And Ford would agree,
and the pattern
would spread to
Chrysler and others
in the automobile industry.
While not perfect, it then
also spread to other industries
across the country
at its own rate.
So you got oil and gas
and household appliances
and the steel industry
and aerospace,
rubber, electronics, all of
these growing industries,
basically following a
similar wage pattern--
not exactly copying but fitted
to the economic circumstances
of their particular setting.
And so this is what created
that tandem movement
of wages and productivity.
And as the economy
got better, so too
did the average workforce
member and his or her families.
That's the kind of thing
that we then lost since 1980.
That's the kind of
thing we have to find
a new solution to create again.
But the key for us
today is not to try
to go back to the 1940s,
'50s, '60s, or '70s,
but to ask, how can
we create wage norms?
How can we create the
bargaining power for workers
so that we can once
again start to get
wages moving with the overall
growth of the economy?
That's our challenge
moving forward.
We'll talk about how to do
that in future sessions.